SURPRISING POPULARITY:
Recently, I was looking at a list
detailing the most visited websites in the US.
At the top, you had your common culprits. Google,
YouTube, Reddit, Amazon, Facebook, DuckDuckGo…
wait a minute, DuckDuckGo is the 6th most visited
website within the US pulling in 2.3 billion
visits every single month? What the hell? That
means that DuckDuckGo is almost twice as popular
as Bing, an official search engine from Microsoft
who has ChatGPT as a partner. This also means that
DuckDuckGo is also more popular than Instagram,
Twitter, Netflix, Uber, Airbnb, Spotify, and
basically any other service that I didn’t
name at the beginning. If you’re like me,
this is a shocker. I mean, I’ve heard about
DuckDuckGo here and there in passing as some sort
of private alternative to Google search. But I’ve
never actually seen a single person actually
use DuckDuckGo. Also, if I’m being honest,
most of these so-called alternatives never really
make it that far due to just how powerful big tech
is. Things like Signal and BeReal usually just
have 5 seconds of fame before fading into oblivion
never to be heard of again. But that doesn’t
seem to be the case with DuckDuckGo. In fact,
DuckDuckGo boasts a user base of 80 million people
and that was as of 2020. That number is likely
closer to 100 million today. Obviously, these
numbers are nothing in direct comparison Google
but in comparison to everything else, it’s
insane. But not only has DuckDuckGo grown to
insane heights but they’ve also stood the test
of time. DuckDuckGo launched on February 29,
2008 meaning that they’ve been going for nearly
16 years at this point, or about the same time
as Bing. But unlike Bing, DuckDuckGo didn’t have
the full power and might of Microsoft behind them.
They started off as just a no name player and
have quietly risen to be one of the most popular
websites not just in the US but around the world
where they rank as the 10th most visited website.
So here’s the insane story of DuckDuckGo and
how they were able single handedly break into
the cutthroat search engine market and take
on some of the biggest companies in the world.
HUMBLE BEGINNINGS:
Taking a look back, the story of DuckDuckGo
takes us back to the village of Valley Forge,
Pennsylvania to a man named Gabriel Weinberg. Over
the years, Gabriel has kept a pretty low profile
which is not all the surprising given the type of
business that he runs. There’s almost nothing
about his childhood online other than the fact
that he was born on New Years Day of 1979 and he
attended local schools. What we can assume though
is that Gabriel was extremely sharp as he would
end up attending MIT on two separate occasions.
Once for his bachelors where he majored in Physics
and once for his masters where he majored in
Technology Policy. He didn’t just jump straight
into DuckDuckGo after college though. In fact,
Gabriel ran multiple ventures before DuckDuckGo.
The first of these was an educational product
called learnection. The goal of learnection was to
increase parental involvement in primary schools,
and though it was a noble cause, it didn’t really
go anywhere. He would end up spending 2.5 years on
it before trying to sell it to a non profit. But
after those talks fell through, he would just go
on to work at the non profit instead to save up
some money. Using this cash, he would go on to
create another startup called NamesDatabase in
2003. A rather unoriginal name but it did have
a rather novel concept. It was basically a social
media site that made it easy to find people that
you went to high school and college with. In
order to search on the website, you could either
pay a membership fee or refer someone else to the
website which is quite a clever growth strategy.
Within just a few years, NamesDatabase would grow
to 20 million free users and 50,000 paying users.
But, despite the success of NamesDatabase, Gabriel
was self admittedly not all that interested in the
product itself. So, he would end up selling a good
offer came around from their biggest competitor
Classmates.com for an estimated $10 million in
cash in March of 2006. Most people would’ve just
called it quits right here. After all, having
$10 million by the time your 30 means that you
could just invest the money well and end up as
a billionaire by the time you die. But, Gabriel
didn’t sell NamesDatabase to take things easy. He
sold it so that he could spend all his effort on
something that he truly believed in and could work
on for decades. The only issue is that he didn’t
exactly know what that was, so he would just spend
his time working on a bunch of side projects that
he found interesting. One of these side projects
was a Google search results optimizer. The tool
would try to filter out spam and content farms
and prioritize results from websites with direct
answers to the search. Gabriel would further build
upon this idea over the course of an year until he
ended up with his own search engine that he would
dub DuckDuckGo.com. If you’ve ever wondered what
the name means, well then, I’m sorry to say that
there is no real meaning to the name. It was just
something that popped into Gabriel’s head one
day when he was thinking about the childrens game
Duck, Duck, Goose and he ran with it. Clearly,
Gabriel isn’t all that into naming and branding,
but he did choose a rather auspicious
day to launch DuckDuckGo: February 29,
2008. And with that, Gabriel had officially
began the uphill journey of taking on Google.
WHY DUCKDUCKGO?:
Shortly after launch, DuckDuckGo did receive
some notable press coverage. For example, they
would be featured on TechCrunch’s Elevator Pitch
Friday in December of 2008. They would also end up
as a finalist on the BOSS Mashable Challenge. But,
while this press coverage definitely didn’t
hurt, the key to DuckDuckGo’s growth has
always just been word of mouth. People tell their
friends about this private alternative to Google,
they give it a shot, they like it, and then
they tell more people about it. Hearing this,
you’re probably wondering what’s so special about
DuckDuckGo in the first place. Well, obviously,
it offers privacy but it goes much deeper than
just that and it’s completely different to
something like incognito on Chrome. All incognito
does is is locally delete your search history
after you close the browser. Incognito doesn’t do
anything to stop websites or Google from tracking
your history. In fact, Google will usually be
helping these websites continue to track you.
If you didn’t know, Google is by far the
most popular choice for companies to track
website activity. You know, what’s the click
through rate, how long is the average session,
what time of day are people visiting, how likely
are they to convert, and so much more. In fact,
75% of the top one million websites in the
world use Google trackers to optimize their
business. And Facebook trackers are present on
25% of the top websites. As a website owner,
these analytics tools are a god send but as a
user, they’re not all that great. The good news is
that DuckDuckGo actively tries to block as many of
these trackers as possible. So, using DuckDuckGo
not only gives you more privacy when searching
but it makes your more invisible across the web
in general. Also this often makes websites a lot
faster as these trackers won’t be bogging down
performance. Putting privacy and performance aside
though, the benefit that intrigues me the most
is actually search quality. Now, this might be a
bit confusing to hear. How could a small startup
possibly have better quality search results
than Google? Well, for one, DuckDuckGo isn’t
as incentivized as Google to push their own
ads meaning that you’ll see less ads but more
importantly, DuckDuckGo doesn’t try to pander to
your thoughts and beliefs. You see, Google’s main
goal isn’t to deliver to you the best and most
accurate search results possible. It’s actually
in their best interest to show you search results
that best align with what you already think. This
way, you’re pleased with what you see and are
more likely to continue your Googling session. On
a broad scale, this means that if you lean left,
you’re likely to be fed CNN and NBC news articles,
and if you lean right, you’re likely to be fed Fox
and Daily Wire news articles. But this works on a
much more micro scale as well. If you think that
Lucids are way better than Teslas, then you’re
likely to find reviews that praise Lucids even if
that’s the minority of reviews. DuckDuckGo on the
other hand doesn’t know anything about you meaning
that they couldn’t curate results based on your
interests even if they wanted to. So, DuckDuckGo
basically offers a more private internet
experience with less ads, better performance, and
no bias. No wonder so many people who are in the
know have opted for DuckDuckGo. But, despite
everything that’s going for DuckDuckGo, taking
on Google is obviously still no easy task, which
brings us into the growing pains of DuckDuckGo.
GROWING PAINS:
One of the first struggles that DuckDuckGo
ran into was funding. For obvious reasons, self
funding a popular search platform is rather
expensive, especially when you’re collecting no
data and showing fewer ads. For example, even with
1.5 million searches per day, DuckDuckGo was only
pulling in $115,000 per year which was probably
not enough to even pay just their modest 3
employees. Fortunately though, in late 2011, Union
Square Ventures would agree to back DuckDuckGo
with $3 to $5 million which has gone a long way
in helping them scale. But just as they finished
addressing their funding issue, they would run
into another issue: Google. You see, it just so
happened that Google owned the domain duck.com.
Google wasn’t even trying to spite DuckDuckGo.
Google had bought up a bunch of domains with
simple words early on in case they ever wanted to
use them and duck.com just happened to be one of
them. Once they realized this though, they would
turn around use it to spite DuckDuckGo. They would
basically just make duck.com redirect to Google
search. Honestly, from an outside perspective,
this was quite a funny troll move. But, I’m sure
it sure it felt a lot different from DuckDuckGo's
perspective. Not only where they not able to lock
in duck.com, but duck.com was actively directing
potential users to Google. Forutantely though,
Google would eventually come around. Whether this
was truly out of good will or just a way to avoid
anti trust litigation, Google would hand over the
domain to DuckDuckGo in 2018 allowing them to
largely clear up the confusion. But even now,
DuckDuckGo is still not truly independent from big
tech. Ironically, their biggest challenge now is
not Google but actually Microsoft. You see,
DuckDuckGo doesn’t actually run any of their
own searches. They’re more like a middle ware.
Whenever you search, they go ahead and mask your
identity and run the search through Bing. From
there, they’ll filter the results returned by
Bing, remove trackers and targeted ads, and show
you the remaining results. For obvious reasons,
Microsoft isn’t exactly the biggest fan of this
solution leading to a constant back and forth
battle between DuckDuckGo and Microsoft regarding
unmasking and remasking users. Despite all these
challenges, DuckDuckGo has managed to come out on
top in terms of popularity, though it is unlikely
that they’ll ever be a true financial hit just
due to how their business is structure. While
they are profitable, they only pull in $100
million in annual revenue despite controlling
2.5% of the search market. In other words, even
if they controlled 100% of the US search market,
they’d only be pulling in $4 billion. If we throw
in the rest of the globe, it might push that up to
$10 billion but that’s still nothing compared to
Google. 58% of Google’s revenue still comes from
search ads which adds up to $162 billion every
single year. So, DuckDuckGo won’t be living up
to that anytime soon, but that was never their
goal anyway. Their goal was just to create a
modest profitable private alternative to Google
and that’s exactly what they’ve done to great
success. Would you consider using DuckDuckGo
over Google? Comment that down below. Another
community oriented business that’s killing it is
Craiglist. Check out this video to learn more.